hola Luis a banjo on my Jeb would you
booboo jolly Jolly my name Toni born is
Lee or money wah or money Pepe this
chance is called you Ricky my
grandmother used to sing it to me when I
was a child in Nigeria sialyl it is a
song of praise of the Yoruba people and
this Paschal Erica speaks of treasures
that the West does not have mama that's
what I call my grandmother told me many
stories about the Oba metallurgy you see
the euro bazaar an ethnic group from the
southwestern part of Nigeria and I was
always fascinated by his stories I was
always intrigued and Yoruba culture has
inspired my art since I was a child it's
the African art is not just what you buy
Harlem market in New York every artist
has a name and every artist has a story
this is my story see mama had tattoos on
her arms and her legs that's a child I
thought she was born with them to a
beautiful black line and detailed
symbols and then she told me that they
were actually symbols from the Yoruba
mythology I never knew how this was
dueling influenced the artists that I am
today you see as a young child I saw art
everywhere I remember the house we live
in is Lauren in Stadium Road we had
marble floors and you know I would look
at the marble floors and I would see all
sorts of patterns and designs in it I
thought everybody could see them so I
would call my brother I like you Kelly
come and see this marble design cities
pattern cities masks and he would tell
me loud ooh I don't see anything so I
would use ink and I'll trace out what I
saw on the floor and then when my mom
noticed she got really upset but that
didn't stop me I switched from egg to
talk because I got in trouble a lot with
my teachers and my parents so I remember
my mom said loudly we are Christians why
don't you draw like other people why
don't you draw you know landscapes or
maybe you draw chairs or furniture or
maybe you even draw Jesus
you know I could paint the whole house
if I had the chance but when I grew up I
knew being an artist was not an option
so I wanted to be the person my parents
when I mean to be so I went to law
school of course that's my dad day he
was so proud of that day and this was
what my notebooks looked like in law
school of course I would miss classes
and I'll make up excuses why you know I
wasn't going to class when I started
working at the Human Rights Commission
as a human rights attorney
my mind was elsewhere I saw a very tough
reality I worked with children who had
to choose between getting an education
and actually being forced into marriage
our so far suite has seen all the
injustice around me and my only outlet
was art so I started painting this piece
is called dreamscape so when you zoom
into this piece you're gonna see a girl
child and the accident of birth the fact
that our future is controlled by where
we are born now the next one you see a
man and a man holding hands a woman and
a woman holding hands you see in Nigeria
same-sex relationship is criminalized
you can actually get 14 years for that
with my art I like to tell stories with
my arts I like to start a conversation
so in this one you see the map of Africa
you see the questions see crying and
then you see syringes plugged into
Africa and the natural resources being
drained out so I asked myself where does
he go who benefits from all of this you
see with my art the way I weave my art
around the patterns the masks the
stories and the way I use my lines it's
all from the Yoruba culture so in 2013 I
made a big gamble I quit my job and I
moved to New York City to practice art
full-time cause my parents are like oh
it's gonna bring weight he'll come back
but life as an artist in New York was
not easy because I was broke
no money no gallery agents no
representation so no gallery will show
my work so I thought to myself I need to
survive so I started painting on clothes
to make a living I said I painted on
shoes
I started customizing things for people
and then soon I realized the power
because people were so proud to wear
that their stories so I started painting
on everything I paint on guitars started
doing new roles anything I could find my
hand and I painted and everything became
my canvas so one day I was just I was
going on my Instagram feed and I saw
this picture was rain she was she took a
picture standing in front of my art and
the moment I saw that photo something
happened in that moment I could actually
see my artwork go into her and come out
of her literally and that's how I
started painting on human bodies as a
child I saw art on the marble floors
I saw art or walls but now I see art on
people's faces on people's bodies I
remember my grandmother and I realized
that most of my creative instincts were
actually based on my childhood memories
and the art of my mother's can now I
look at all the blue black paints and I
think to my son I'm like what would you
look like if we all walked around like
gods and goddesses from Yoruba mythology
and boom that is how the sacred out of
the Ori was born you see Ori in Yoruba
mythology means your soul it means your
essence it means your instincts and I
realized that only when you tap into
your only then you can actually move
mountains so and something so so
immediate about painting on human body
it's something so it's like art in
motion it's like a 3d experience so one
day I was just doing my regular work and
and Brooklyn and I got an email that
said hi I'm a big fan of your work
would you like to paint in my music
video signed Beyonce like Beyonce me
okay I was like what how did she even
know me I thought this can't be true of
course I thought it was a scam Nigeria
was like nah
[Laughter]
but incredibly enough it was real was
true and things happen really fast you
see we also wanted to pay homage to New
Orleans and my art marry her off of her
Creole origins so when lemonade dropped
of course boom everything just went from
zero to 100 real fast people featured me
in magazines interviews people stopped
me in the street people knew my name
like and sometimes I just step back I
just chill and like take everything in
you know as artists we work so hard all
our lives for art to be recognized and
for this I feel blessed
however the attorney me is still there
so I used my art to fight for what I
believe in my Yoruba heritage is always
there well I like to share with you
tonight some of my art in motion please
welcome with me on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
now this is jelly and this is rain this
are the first two people I ever been
said in my life and I spent the past day
painting on them tonight
they represent my hopes are my fears now
I pull my peers on the back I put my
hopes in front what are my hopes I hope
that people know that Africa is not just
one huge nameless continent that is all
the same I also hope that people know
that in Nigeria we have over 350 ethnic
groups and languages and I am just one
artist from one of them I also hope that
you know that I hope I'll be able to
change the way people talk about African
arts on the continents and here and I
hope you know the African artists not
just watch you buy our Harlem markets in
New York and that every piece of art you
see has a story and every artist has a
name
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]